hello and welcome to this video playing
book slick yeah let's switch to e4 one
in what in place here especially cause
unless you get most of the time actually
when the night c 2 nit success played on
move to cool night maneuvers him a black
not bad ok so maybe tick now recreate
win any turn need to color in for oh my
is really playing like every move
instantly like it is all theory I cannot
believe that
even extremely committal moves like
capturing played instantly so let's see
what happens here
so 96 to defy it doesn't do much but
still
and clean is pretty pretty annoying
piece down and going to try to trade it
I wonder if f3s coach ever let's do it
under any threats currently I don't see
nh4 I can take King h7 see going for
that I just blended CB 3m it's a way to
lose the game that's very unfortunate
maybe I get it back but that was not ah
yes Daniel oh great great I always hate
to do it against those instant movers
but sometimes it happens I mean they
play good mood once in a while even
though they do it immediately like him
I include you full well that all the
crap game a really really bad game ah
what is that no idea I'm out looking at
hectic again I actually can do that to
do that again now not you and not crazy
for
okay okay yeah I have a trade it's Queen
f3 and queen have one and they are both
both threatened
and it's very easy very easy stuff is
the problem take in your way for some
tricks could take the Queen like this so
go back then and but Queen d7 I can
actually continue the game with the
stuff like look at six for example
somehow continues
nine is six doesn't wait and see five at
the end which threatens stuff now that
is actually interesting okay maybe he
does something else and not take the
night the speed is flying is taking it
instantly now look at seven is a threat
and sometimes Queen f7 Bishop g7 who
have seven Queen takes a check the true
I'm somewhat back in business here I
wonder Bishop g7 I have something better
you can look at sell this one and now I
can take with the time or excellent can
take with the pond where's he going man
I don't know you cannot play an active
move Queen B seven maybe i'll just take
with the rook Queen B seven is attacking
me for unfortunately okay I have to
check with the rook that's not so great
in comparison now Queen d7 del c 6 and
then winning actually so interesting
nice bouquet age is queens got 27 hun
man is what's getting interesting again
and still I've got lost position i am
kim okay cool see one is unfortunately
winning a plant okay seven now it is
somewhat ever threaten check is ignored
what check check check where's the mate
adoncia made unfortunately i can take
here in a jealous wings at the time is a
problem Queen have three am anticipating
somehow three seconds three bloody
seconds check check check check check
[Music]
check gained crew Oh
what again what they made that I want to
check that first yeah if I can't ever
made after he he stumbled into all that
let me check i want to see you haven't
made your deck so yeah so creative and
so on taking is immediate made and now i
hope t for their the computer doesn't
find a mate right away so i have to do
this and yeah this is just a problem in
five seconds yeah it's just tougher in
five seconds i made a couple of most
yeah well it was a pretty dreadful game
pretty dreadful name helpful and played
the opening in something all those super
committee loose or played in a second
and now yes I don't know maybe this
isn't right f F takes I don't know it
opened up the f file but it seems to be
okay for him when he gets there very
quickly with with the pieces and it
doesn't matter that this is a bad
structure for black now go on sorry that
wasn't intended yeah this position isn't
any good there really isn't any good
group h2 and King edge one is keeping by
the engine now this is already a pretty
pretty sad position yeah now i blundered
this yeah I mean yeah I'm totally lost
you just simply am did not want to play
green juice or for some reason janitor
didn't really understand check
Here I am somewhat continuing at least
ok and now ya hear there were
alternatives 94 was winning instead this
and now see final things are not CLE at
all how they are clear 26 is just plus a
million ok very easier yeah thing is if
you have so many good looking
alternatives I mean this is also do good
I but he has this and all of a sudden
there is counter play Angie I'm losing
again so hand Queenie six right okay
just came again stumbled into a lost
position that's really weird moment I
mean I'm threatening this very obviously
you can play whatever change that he
walks into this checkmate basically
which I wasn't able to complete two wins
because 13 seconds is not looked a lot
of time ok guys thanks for watching